welcome to Casa de Juan
I love you we like the friends we like
our uncles and our stairs
see I'm gonna play let's just do this
all right so you heard it
um we're in the middle of well I'm in
the middle of rearranging everything
taking down my Christmas decorations
which makes me so sad and I highly
highly highly suggest that you invest in
one of these to keep all of your
ornaments organized and prevent them
from breaking and I also highly highly
highly recommend you getting a fake tree
it is so easy it already comes installed
with lights
what this is the best thing honestly
hands down the best Christmas purchase I
have ever made just within five minutes
my tree is up all I have to do is just
put the decorations which
is the most tedious part but it's always
so fun because I'm like oh this little
ornament this anyway
the house is still a mess I know I talk
about it every single Vlog but it really
does [__] bother me but this time is
for good reason and the reason why it's
good for good reason
is because we're gonna rearrange our
living room yes
so guess what
um
a long time until it was my birthday was
gonna come back
oh yeah okay after Halloween then it's
Thanksgiving and then Christmas
yeah what was the song you were singing
earlier
[Music]
no it was January February
March and you April April
May June June July August September
that's your birthday
October November
December
I love the vibrato
I like Barbara and look look at who's up
there who's out there
do you just want to Vlog yeah I do but
look outside
there she is there's a little girl who's
getting so big so fast yeah
and then here's a little boy that's
getting so big so fast
okay so now the big feet is gonna be
where
one is where I'm gonna put all this
stuff because right now our garage is a
[__] show it's like an absolute [__]
show just because we're we have a bunch
of boxes because half of our items have
landed the other more essential Parts
have been because they're like on back
border because there's so many like
supply chain shortages like for example
we have a dining table that's not going
to be here until like
mid-February and it's such a cool table
but we have the chairs for it but I
can't put the chairs without the table
you know what I mean like it's so weird
so a lot of these big boxes like I have
six chairs so they're all in boxes in
the garage and then here I have like a
bunch of light fixtures that I haven't
had a chance to put up but they will be
going up tomorrow your daughter loves
poop what the [__] what are you doing
what do you think that is
that is [__] what do you mean what I
think that is you saw that right oh my
go away
why don't you
click in here yeah that's true outside
that was funny that was funny
um [__] what I was talking about that
was way more interesting
but yeah no tonight's the night because
we got some chairs some like little
armchairs because right now the [__]
living room is just nothing but couch
and trust me I love it but it just makes
it feel kind of Funkadelic in there for
me so I'm gonna make the couch smaller
luckily it's sectional and I bought
these bad boys and I've been waiting a
month to get them
and I'm tired of waiting
I'm a tired [__] and I want to
rearrange everything like look at our
coffee table this coffee table's been
sitting here for about a month now we
don't even have bar stools because those
are back ordered as well but this my rug
is here those chairs are there so I
thought might as well do it let's get it
started and this guy right here
is a ball of energy
[Music]
just careful because it's a chair okay
no
okay first on the roster
is moving this clearing this section
because what I want to do is take this
section out take this section out take
this section out
because let me show you from this side
because those are the ones that are all
split up
because all I want
is couch from here to here the end
so you see here it's already sectioned
off
there's that line right there so I'm
gonna put these in the yep I'm gonna put
these in the garage move this section
because it's already the end piece
shift that there and then those chairs
that I showed you that were there put
those here
get rid of this retire this coffee table
for a little bit
put that in the garage pull that guy in
oh before I pull that guy in put the rug
in then pull that guy bring it in here
yeah
with the dress
[Applause]
one thing that I did add to this was a
glass top because it is reclaimed wood
and with the toddler and a dog and
myself and bar we're gonna [__] it up so
I opted to do an aftermarket piece and I
added a piece of glass here just to
preserve as much as I can for as long as
I can because if you can see here
she's gonna get [__] up look at all
that
yeah so if I could I mean I'm pretty
sure I can like buff it out or restain
it or I don't know what the
the appropriate thing to do is but at
least here
bam I'll preserve it
a little bit longer and we need to
document this because this man
is putting in work boots matters there's
something about the hat that we have
no hold on
so for some reason the sink right here
the kitchen sink always has a giant pile
up of dirty dishes it's because I don't
do it because I'm not doing it I swear
to God that it's not me and she swears
to God it's not her so both of us say
that we that we're really clean with our
stuff but it's always someone the night
before that leaves someone there leave
something there so the other one is like
well if something's already there I'm
gonna put something in there so that's
how it adds up but we never think once
each of us are the initiators so we're
like all right let's see what who the
actual culprit is so now our bed is okay
first let me tell you what's at stake
what's at stake is a third your pride
minute legit massage and we're talking
about we have to the loser has to buy
the table where the head sticks through
oh yeah baby all the lotions and candles
have you been doing your research I'm
not losing all the hot towels all that
stuff I better get the stones too in the
hot stones and that's what's at stake
so now what it is is
whoever is done with the kitchen
they not only have to leave the kitchen
clean I mean the sink clean but the
whole kitchen cleaned so whoever and
what's your definition doesn't clean
because somebody made some protein
powder this morning and it was powder
all over the counter is that what you
mean clean or is that not good that's
fine okay so there's like there's little
there's little loopholes okay
so someone left water like right here
why on the water like this no no no no
there was a cup of water here that's
different why is it different you see I
already feel like you're gonna okay
that's a big one oh my God you see your
recipe book you left your recipe book
that's that's not considered clean
interpreted like that yeah okay then we
have new rules
nothing on the kitchen table thing that
doesn't belong in the kitchen
what do you mean that doesn't belong in
the kitchen my cup belong to the kitchen
with water no but that's not your you
need to use that
perfect
exactly what I was hoping for
yeah back to this what so what can these
Keys be on here it needs to be like um
show ready you remember we were showing
our house and we had to put everything
away mine is like this [__] like I don't
know where to put that but it belongs in
the kitchen now is this show already
this is not sure already at all well
where would I put it where would you put
it because this is this is for both of
us what are the rules now now it gets
now it gets [__] technical exactly
yeah so then what is it because you said
that nothing on the counter you said it
has to be clean generally it has to be
clean like obviously if there's a
chocolate milk here yeah that's dirty
that's dirty okay water that's fine all
right you know what I'm saying if
there's a spoon with a little bit of
peanut butter just right there no 30.
yep all right fine that's the rule I'll
give it to you
Mia Savor him
yeah Mia getting me again
what happened
what happened Mia
get him here get him get him get him you
get
her little her little claws
that is such a big bed for taika
the Beast
progress has been made took off my
sweater for one but look at this
we're down to our last two sections I
just mopped the floor I'm about to open
this guy
let's check out
God this house is never gonna be
clean I swear
but
for now
we've moved things over into our garage
until we can figure some [__] out right
there those big boxes are are our
um refrigerator
we've been waiting on a [__] panel
for two months and that's why we have
that little refrigerator in there and
that's why it's taking up so much space
but yes looking to clean things
at some point but for now
this is where to live
so we got tired of taking care of taika
so we put him in a cage right Tyga who
put you in the cage
yourself why'd you put it can you pause
it real quick
how come you put yourself in the cage
but you don't look like you're relaxing
there's no there's no
yeah oh okay I'll Trust you okay
[Music]
oh boys no that's Mia's bed that's what
she puts her yucky butt and all her pee
pee Paws go in there am I bringing you
pillows
okay all right so more progress this
feels really good does it yeah
um oh it does okay
okay so this is
our rug I like it because of all the
tones but can I be honest you guys I
didn't read the description and I was
solely looking at the colors and I was
like oh these colors are beautiful this
is perfect and it wasn't until I
received it and I saw it and I rolled it
out
and bruh it's [__]
cowhide
it's rough
and I'm trying to just go whatever why
am I trying to be a hypocrite like I eat
meat I wear leather like why is this any
different
car seats have leather I know my seats
are made out of [__] leather my
Timberland boots I see you walk in that
leather
anyway I love the colors now we gotta
lay out the brand new chairs and then
put these bad boys back in place and
hopefully
it looks good because I've never seen
anything I bought in person
so I just did some measurements here and
there I'm like I think it'll fit and
eyeballed everything and kind of just
did like a mood board type of deal but
this is me seeing everything for the
first time so
I'm nervous why are you nervous this is
all 100 my eye you know my Decor my
amateur Decor eye whoops oh sorry
um like this one is it
it's suede right dirty is it suede yeah
but it's a performance suede I got it
like this on purpose yeah there's one
that was way more luxurious
um but that one isn't as durable as this
one so this is the one for children
exactly you can wash it like it's I
forgot the description but it's really
durable well does it look like the way
you wanted it
because the way we picked this chair out
was literally she saw the chair like
structure and model that she likes and
then we went into the store and she had
picked out a Swatch and then from this
tiny Swatch you kind of have to like you
know sometimes things get either darker
or lighter so did it turn out the way
you wanted to yeah
we gotta install this ourselves uh
okay
update
I kind of love it I kind of love it I
need more Pops of color here and there
so ignore that those are like the final
layers of things like I want to put
Plants so I think green and maybe some
like I don't know tints of like pink
maybe yellow like pastel I think that
but check this out
I would like in it
yeah my beautiful velvet look at these
beautiful chairs
yeah I love it so the thing I'm I'm
contemplating is moving the rug over
about a foot so it comes out this way
and then we'll move in the coffee table
and now this space just opened up
significantly grub
I'm in love
I love it I love it I love it I love it
yay and then tomorrow adding chandeliers
pendant lighting
this chandelier hasn't arrived yet but
[__] it we'll wait but yes it's coming
together
oh my CUNY guys
that's a good chair this is what I
wanted
okay so it's morning time and I wanted
to see the living room a little bit in a
different light with just a few more
items
in it because last night I just felt
like the same I don't know it just felt
a little flat for me and even though I
know I'm gonna add more Pops of color
and texture in the space
I have little patience I have little
patience so I'm like I gotta see in the
morning I gotta add like a couple
elements here and there
um so it's morning time now
this isn't the final form by any means
but just to kind of show you little pops
of color I mean obviously we're not done
but
even just this little Orchid that I have
been I was gonna say raising but
basically raising for a few months now
it is thriving brother look at this she
is gorgeous I have never done that in my
life but the fact that I've had it for
this long alive
Jamie what are you doing who gave you
this oh my God look at your eye dude
close
go ahead let's see that see the green
thing that's part of this oh you have a
diamond don't do it on top because
you're gonna end up cracking this thing
wow who gave this to you Uncle David I
think yeah David gave this to you thank
you David for all the mess
all right so on that note I'm just gonna
end it here
um I'll continue to build upon you know
our house our living room so stay tuned
for more home updates if you will I'm
learning because this is the first time
I'm actually 100 decorating my own house
whereas before I would just look at the
floor and be like give me that whole
floor
however the designer did it give me all
of it you know how they have to display
thingies like the displays on the floor
I was like I'll take the whole floor
thank you this is the first time I'm
going I'm gonna do it myself so
this is not nerve wracking at all that's
just a house right it's not a big deal
we got this let's do it
oh yeah and on that note thank you so
much for watching stay tuned for more
um house updates
it's gonna be fun
oh man we're still opening boxes we got
my brother
installing some stuff
the man he's the best he drove from
California
to install he's an electrician so he's
doing everything for me over here
look at this bowl
[Music]
and Grandma came and she's probably
cussing me out
oh that's a first what
what had some breakfast Krispy Kremes
this right here I bought four of these
pendant lights that are gonna go up in
my kitchen they're so cute two out of
the four are broken like the base is
like so it's wood here and then it's a
glass base
two of the four
the glass came broken so I have to see
with Crate and Barrel if I can just go
pick it up because I don't want them to
be sold out because I need minimum three
so we'll see I gotta return it and I
bought these back in November it's
January
I just haven't had time to install
anything so we'll see what happens
oh yeah
you got him
burp quad
I'm about to sneeze butts today's been a
long day not that I've been doing much
but I kind of have been supervising a
lot I don't know so as you know my
brother came over
he just installed a bunch of stuff look
at this
so we have a bunch of empty boxes which
is my absolute favorite because that
just means I get my home bag look at
that
look at these light fixtures y'all
oh
they are just absolutely perfect and
then look at these bad boys so these I
initially bought four of them okay this
lighting is just horrendous let me just
Mia what do you got in there a ball
let me just fix the lights here real
quick
so ow what the he just smacked me
yeah that's what they look like with the
lights on
and then these oh let me turn these
this is what they look like
they're so beautiful look at these
so again I wanted to keep the gold metal
metal gold at a minimum because we're
gonna have a big ass metal fridge
there's a lot of like metal fixtures
here and there so I wanted to keep those
to a minimum but still kind of tied all
together but the most important thing
that I wanted are just
naturally occurring elements and
textures inside this house so I opted
for wood here and you can see it's glass
so you can already see it here it ties
in the beams and then I'm going to have
some wood bar stools which is going to
tie in this room here so I need more
accents and colors and Pops of colors
like I was mentioning in the last vlog
um but yeah
I have two more you see there so I
initially ordered four when they
delivered it this right here was broken
I got them from Crate and Barrel and
cream Barrel is freaking awesome because
I bought these in November
when I bought them they're actually like
400 bucks a piece which is you know
expensive but considering this is gonna
be in your house for a long time and you
want quality items it's actually the
reason reasonably priced because the
quality is actually pretty damn good
um so I
this camera's gonna die darn it let me
charge my camera
I feel like a SpongeBob episode where I
go two hours later because it was
literally two hours later
um I was talking about my pendant lights
yes so return these and it was so dope
of Crate and Barrel because it was past
the 30 days that you can refund [__]
they didn't give a [__] they refunded it
and because they refunded it I bought
two of the exact same ones
and when I bought them they were more
expensive I think they were like no 500
bucks so then I called I was like um
I am so Shameless I went past the 30
days that you said I can't refund it you
didn't even ask me or question me on it
you refunded me but when I first bought
them they were like 100 bucks cheaper
can we price match and they were like
the bestie of course let's do it and I
was like [__] you just gained a loyal
ass [__] you know what I'm saying
[__] crate Barrel can get it but yeah
thank you cranbro
um we're always always my whole living
room was [__] Crate and Barrel what
is going on
[__] cute
Mia is dead and papa is dead Mia
are you broken
me are you broken
yo Papa get up
me and my cute little baby girl your
papa
get your human ass up
my little baby girl she's so cute dude
how old are you can you please get him
Papa
yeah
my little sin rug
I call it a sin rug because it was like
way too animal real life animal for me I
know I'm a hypocrite I get it okay
so back to the installation so yeah
these guys have been installed we
installed cameras all around our house
which is makes me feel Ultra extra
amazing safe
went to sleep now so I'm gonna have to
whisper
door
I got these from Restoration Hardware
let me turn it off and you can see the
design better
freaking pretty are they
okay
and then
in the guest bedroom
I installed
I didn't know my brother did
oh yeah
look at how [__]
comfortable this looks imagine
staring at this oh yes
and this is like way more wood
include the frame oh man just relaxes me
just looking at it just this right here
look at that
okay so I've added that
oh yeah
chandelier in my room that's
90 done
just because
I'll show you
let's go to my room show
so
Chandelier
it is so wow so pretty because it's got
like glass bulbs but they're not just
regular glass it's like
they have like texture to it it's really
really beautiful
and then you have like these little
crystal balls but they're supposed to be
balls all over so where there's an
exposed
um shed a lot candelabra light bulb
one of those Globes is supposed to go
over it but with these candelabras
there's a tip
it was okay with this bowl because it's
bigger
these bulbs are smaller
so To Shimmy it in there it's kind of
impossible oh you can see the texture
here in this one which one of them is
very unique
and I liked it because it's a very
soothing at night
so it has like this like softening
effect and every single one of them is
different than the other
this one's a little bit lighter
it gives it this very organic
feeling to it
look at them so damn pretty but yeah
these candelabras a little bit too long
on the tip
to make it fit on these I have to find
some that are a little bit stubbier but
you can already imagine
how freaking gorgeous this is gonna look
I love it I love it I love it because
the room itself is just so
square and like sharp Corners that like
something round and full
it was very necessary God I love these
little bulbs so dope
ah I'm stoked super super stuck let me
interview Bart because
I hate leaving lights on
but yeah and I was designing this whoops
I'm gonna get my life together
when I was designing this I never once
visited a store to like put shirt
together everything was done online and
it said I created a mood board and I
really wasn't sure how everything was
gonna look
so far it feels like it's coming
together Papa
can I interview you
well maybe Mia first
speechless she says I did a great job
okay so you were with me
the entire design phase
did you show them your mood boards and
stuff oh no not yet
someday someday
someday because you actually put in a
lot of work I think if they don't know
that you did that whole process it
seemed like you just bought stuff but
you had it all preset pre-planned yeah I
did I'll show them one day
I was just trying to make it seem like I
was like this really
um genius interior designer but you are
you blew my cover no that's the genius
part of it you did the pre-planning
that's that's the genius part of it you
did it just like the interior designer
would fine thank you so you're here
tonight
yeah she's feeling good she's confused
okay
so
we're not obviously at the finish line
yet there's still a lot that needs to
happen
but so far seeing all of the process
to now where We've Ended up what are
your thoughts
these aren't my thoughts when's the last
time you saw me lay down in the living
room well we didn't have a rug before
exactly I hope you feel comfy in my own
home finally the wife's doing a goddamn
job okay before I [__] cut this clip
punch your [__] nuts off then record
again with you being all sad let's jump
to the real stuff okay that's the real
stuff what do you think how's it coming
up Advance come together really good
because I think when you show me your
move or what we're going for it
very cozy but also clean and looks like
a model home I think it's getting there
like things are looking very aesthetic
really pulled together but some model
homes feel really stiff and like like oh
don't touch anything it feels very
livable still and very comfy
such a good job
you get a really really
are there these things would you have
purchased them on your own no because I
don't have a good taste like you
I don't think I have good taste but yeah
impeccable taste when it comes to
Furniture oh thank you very much you
trying to get lucky hey
[Music]
after after a long day of
supervising
I did supervise okay my brother did all
the work
um
very grateful for that and I do
appreciate and respect this line of work
and he's also my brothers I just don't
ever want him to work by himself so I'm
only just trying to like supervise and
make his life easy so I'm like if that
means opening up all the boxes and
setting up all the next things that are
coming out like I just really try to be
present and like there for him
and that just really took a toll on me
so they've left
they're about
maybe 40 minutes away from making it
home now at this point it is raining
they're probably taking it slower so
we'll say about they have an hour left
to get home it is 9 30 now so they'll
get home like 10 30.
and I actually like it because
um I know my mom doesn't really get to
spend much time with him one-on-one
um he is a man and he does take care of
his family and he's got like four kids
and a wife
so it's really hard to have that alone
time so I kind of really do like that
they're together in a car right now for
four hours
on that note I'm together with this
hubby hubs who's kind of feeling under
the weather as am I I don't know what is
going on but I have like I don't know
Bart got sick I think maybe from the
theme or something brought the cold back
home
all I have is a runny nose congestion
that's kind of it
so just drink some Theraflu Papa's
drinking some Theraflu about to drink
another round
of T this one is a sleepy time tea you
know the one with the bear on the box
like I want to be that bear with those
slippers
and the PJs with the like hat on top
that's what I'm trying to accomplish
tonight what I'm saying
so I'm gonna drink some of that get warm
from the inside out and eat one of these
guys what are these guys called Papa
this is a Chinese snack what is it
called
why Coffee Tree
everybody want to keep that
he says a white puppy tree
you're the only person that walks around
with the natural frown
thank God you're happy no no yours I do
have a resting [__] I will not lie
about that but your lips just your
natural state they just droop look
they just droop
s thank God you're such a jolly dude
let me see look at me they go down why
you just know you don't even have to do
that
you just do that
that's just neutral that's a zero
you're creepy foreign
okay so I'm about to enjoy my [__]
Chinese snack that's not called White
whippy treat
um and I'm gonna bust the Mia oh [__]
she's out again me and you were just
awake dude
what there she is
bustamia and knock the [__]
cause tomorrow I'm gonna do it all over
again but get rid of those boxes clean a
little bit more make this house feel
more and more like a home I'm so stoked
it is raining outside too so I don't
know I might take the boy up to the
mountain catch some snow or I just you
know go hiking in the rain I'm not I'm
not too sure yet but the boy and the
girl need to go out they just get too
many wiggles I know I can work [__]
all day
their kids both of them oh cute
are you trying to do that to them I
don't want to keep them locked up so if
I can get their wiggles out in the
morning I'm gonna try and do that
that's all mine
on that note
good night see you guys tomorrow